this is book from thailand and you're
watching
ojoto tv
my real name is nopalut him pomon
i am 23 years old and now i'm a
professional chicken player for thailand
eastbourne
yeah this is gonna hurt you probably
gonna get the wall oh my
okay okay one more chance taxi down
three three
my sidewalks marched up i live in
bangkok
thailand my first play taken is
tekken 6 when i was 12 years old
[Music]
i took taken seriously since 2017
that's three years ago
[Music]
because the first time i see jin
i feel i watching myself my
thought is i have to play this character
so book takes it congratulations bookie
is the champion here
at southeast asian majors my favorite
math
i have so far is against artif but
in lcq versus pakistan
this is a big match like i said
because that match is so many emotional
for me i played my home country
i am the one who not expect to win the
tournament not even the one in the list
the top three country will win
in lcq people keeps talking
pakistan will win that's made me more
pleasure to play against him that might
be enough damage is it that
[Music]
run away
oh
bracket here at the ltq and makes it
into the top
on the winner's side the local hero here
we go talent
book my best moment
in tekken is in lcq we are back here
technical
finals lcq action i realized
many things in lcq and i can be the
player that
i never expect before i did something
that
many people did not expect
and my place is third place it's not a
winner
but i'm satisfied
my advice for explaining player
watching top gen player gameplay
you will learn a lot stuff from them at
first
you might copy them their style keep
playing practice and someday you can
make your own style
don't do it don't do it oh that was
beautiful
i love that song anybody's game still
woah
thank you for watching this video you
can also
follow and watch me stream by click the
link
in the description and make sure you
follow osho tv thank you
you